the prostate gland is a walnut-sized
gland in men it is located at the base
of the bladder and wraps around the
urethra cancer of the prostate is one of
the most common types of cancer in men
radical prostatectomy is a surgical
procedure in which the prostate gland
surrounding tissue and seminal vesicles
are removed depending on your situation
your surgeon may also choose to remove
some lymph nodes
just before your surgery an intravenous
line will be started you may be given
antibiotics through the IV to decrease
your chance of infection
you'll be given general spinal or
epidural anesthesia if you receive
general anesthesia a breathing tube will
be inserted through your mouth and down
your throat to help you breathe during
the operation
if you receive spinal or epidural
anesthesia
you won't need a breathing tube you'll
be given sedation to help you relax
radical prostatectomy can take between
90 minutes and 4 hours 3 different
approaches may be used open retro pubic
open pernil or laparoscopic
in an open retro pubic prostatectomy the
prostate is removed through an incision
in the lower part of the abdomen in an
open perineal prostatectomy the prostate
is removed through an incision in the
perineum which lies between the rectum
and the scrotum and laparoscopic
prostatectomy your surgeon places
instruments into your abdominal cavity
through small keyhole incisions or ports
he or she dissects the prostate from its
surrounding structures and removes the
gland through one of the slightly
widened ports depending on whether the
cancer has spread your surgeon may also
remove tissue surrounding the prostate
gland including the seminal vesicles and
lymph nodes regardless of the type of
procedure your surgeon will carefully
inspect the area around the prostate
before removing any tissue taking care
to minimize damage to nerves in the area
at the end of the operative procedure a
catheter would be put into your bladder
to keep it drained this will usually be
left in place for 10 days to two weeks
after surgery soon after your surgery
your breathing tube will be removed and
you will be taken to the post surgical
recovery area for monitoring you will be
given pain medication as needed you may
continue to receive antibiotics through
your IV your bladder may be flushed
intermittently with a sterile solution
to wash out accumulated blood and clots
most patients are released from the
hospital
two days after the procedure